want to get this right top White House
officials are trying to discredit dr.
Anthony Fauci with a list of talking
points challenging his work the
government's top infectious disease
expert faces new criticism from inside
the coronavirus task force one top
administration trade official that's
advisor Peter Navarro went on the record
and told CBS News quote doctor foul Qi
has a good bedside manner with the
public but he has been wrong about
everything I've ever interacted with him
on weecha jiang is at the White House
with more on this story good morning to
you we sure this can't be helpful what
is this all about a good morning to you
Gail polls show that public people in
the public still widely trust dr. Fauci
but in a stunning development some
administration officials are treating
him like a political rival releasing
what they say is a list of questionable
statements by dr. Falchi even though
many of them were taken out of context
or widely accepted in the early days of
the pandemic dr. Fauci said don't wear
masks and now he says worm and he said
numerous things don't in a recently
released interview President Trump
appeared to blame dr. Anthony Fauci for
the administration's mixed messages
about the corona virus
earlier in the pandemic and White House
advisor Peter Navarro issued a statement
listing remarks by Falchi he claims are
inaccurate telling CBS News Falchi is
saying that a falling mortality rate
doesn't matter
pouchy has warned against taking comfort
in the dropping death rate which is no
longer falling there's so many other
things that are very dangerous and bad
about this virus don't get yourself into
false complacency CBS News has learned
that some administration officials
including members of the task force are
frustrated with dr. Fauci because they
believe he has become a source of
controversy and is out for himself
dr. fowey told the Financial Times he
has not briefed President Trump in over
two months but in public he's gotten
more blunt about the crisis compare us
to other countries I don't think you can
say we're doing great I mean we're just
not trying to
line him or diminish him or discredit
him is just atrocious more than three
months after President Trump announced
the CDC's recommendations on face
coverings he wore masks in public for
the first time on Saturday during a
visit to Walter Reed Hospital Surgeon
General Jerome Adams said on Face the
Nation the administration is trying to
correct earlier guidance about wearing
masks you learn more you change those
recommendations our recommendations have
changed okay now people of America
important to know you should wear a face
cover meanwhile a few Republican
lawmakers are calling President Trump's
decision to commute the sentence of
longtime ally Roger stone a mistake with
Utah senator Mitt Romney labeling at
labeling it as historic corruption stone
was set to spend 40 months in prison for
charges linked to the Russia probe over
the weekend special counsel robert
muller said in an op-ed he remains a
convicted felon and rightly so
anthony we should thank you